so what i want to do here is have a
discussion about the justice league
and what i'm hoping is that at the end
of all this you'll have a strong
understanding of how the team originated
as well as how it's changed over the
course of its publication history and dc
comics
so the justice league first appeared in
brave and the bold issue number 28
initially being introduced as an
anthology series for golden age
characters that didn't have a large
enough fan base to warrant their own
solo series
brave and the bold served as a way for
dc to keep these stories going
alongside a series of others in an
anthology format
and that readers could enjoy their
favorite golden age heroes without dc
losing money on low selling titles
however with barry allen's 1956
introduction serving as a way to
reinvigorate interest in dc comics
in october of 1959 the brave and the
bold was switched over to a series that
kept its anthology format
but rather than showcasing golden age
heroes instead the series showcased new
heroes in order to gauge fan reception
for these various creations
as a result in 1960 dc editor julius
schwartz had tasked writer gardner fox
with reintroducing the justice society
of america
originally appearing in 1940 as a way
for dc to experiment with a team of
their most popular characters minus
batman and superman
in order to boost sales during the
golden age comic boom in 2005 in his
book justice league companion historian
michael yuri had stated that when
gardner fox was given this task
because baseball was such a huge part of
american culture and was split into the
american league and national leagues
gardner fox chose to incorporate this
element into the team as a way to
maintain its ties to pop culture
as a result enraven the bold issue
number 28 the justice league was
introduced under the name
justice league of america however
because brave and the bold was a title
based on experimentation
gardner fox did not provide an origin
story for the team in this first issue
instead he treated the team as if it had
already been established and introduced
a villain
named starro as the story goes with
peter the puffer fish communicating with
aquaman it had stated that an alien in
the form of a starfish had arrived on
earth
with the intention of conquering it
modifying two other starfish and turning
them into a replication of itself
aquaman realized that the threat was too
large for him to face on his own
sending out a distress signal gardner
fox established that the original
justice league was composed of wonder
woman superman
batman the green lantern the flash
aquaman and martian manhunter
using this platform gardner fox removed
superman by placing him in deep space
destroying meteors that posed a threat
to the earth
and organized the story in a fashion
that saw the various starro clones
facing off against the rest of the
justice league individually
and a series of mini stories which led
to the main star facing the league
itself
in the first story titled green lantern
vs starro hal jordan found one of the
clones attacking an air force jet
realizing the clone had attacked the jet
for the purpose of acquiring the atomic
bomb it had on board
how jordan is able to save the jet once
it's discarded by the clone
after detonating the atomic bomb the
clone absorbs the energy and while hal
jordan takes a few moments to understand
why
he ends up ignoring this and instead
chooses to attack and destroy the clone
before
it can do anything with the absorbed
energy using the real world physiology
of a starfish in that the center eye
also contains various organs needed for
self-replication
gardner fox establishes that this center
is the weak point attacking it in the
eye
hal jordan is able to cut off the
connection between starro and the clone
causing the starfish to revert back to
its normal form
in the second story the conflict
switches to the perspective of martian
manhunter and wonder woman
with another one of the clones attacking
the hall of science wonder woman
establishes that the greatest scientific
minds of the time work from this
building
intending to capture the greatest minds
in the world the clone takes the hall of
science from its foundation and begins
to carry it away
chasing after it wonder woman uses her
lasso in an attempt to ensnare the clone
and keep it from traveling
further away however because the clone
possesses so much strength
wonder woman is quite literally carried
with it with superman destroying the
meteors before they can reach earth
martian manhunter uses this to his
advantage by allowing the smaller
meteorite fragments to enter the
atmosphere
and uses his breath to blow them at the
clone with wonder woman using her lasso
a second time combined with her robot
jet to pull the science hall to safety
the exhaustion of its energy stores
causes the clone to weaken and revert
back to its normal form
transitioning to the flash the comic
picks up in a place called happy harbor
and a teenager named snapper
receiving his nickname due to his
penchant for snapping his fingers
snapper finds a town of happy harbor
under the mental control of one of the
clones
having recently put lime on the front
lawn of his family's home to treat the
grass
snapper finds that he alone is not
affected by the mental powers of the
clone
realizing this the cone attempts to kill
snapper by shooting him with an energy
beam
but barry allen arrives at the last
moment and saves him
engaging the clone in battle barry allen
is able to use his speed to overpower
the clone
retreating to the water barry is able to
follow and uses his feet to vibrate the
lake
and as a result locates the clone and
allows the water to smash into it
killing it in the process and so in the
third part of the story which focuses on
the main
starro we learned that during the
various conflicts the first clone had
relayed the atomic energy it absorbed to
the second clone
the second clone had relayed its
knowledge of the scientists the third
clone
which developed the ability to control
minds using his knowledge
staro intends to force the world's
leaders to detonate all of the atomic
bombs so that it can absorb all of the
radiation
because the world will be destroyed as a
result starro declares that it will use
his experience in this conflict as well
as the power gained to take over other
planets
arriving to defeat starro the flash
realizes the snapper was protected from
the mental powers of the third clone
due to the fact that he had been exposed
to lime using this knowledge hal jordan
takes several barrels of the powder from
a local farmer
and douses staro which kills the alien
and saves the world
furthermore due to his help snappers
made an honorary member of the justice
league
now following the introduction of the
league and brave in the bold the concept
was extremely well received among fans
while the team would go on to be
featured in issues number 29 and 30
in november of 1960 the league received
its own series titled justice league of
america
while the titles were consistently
billed as revolving around the original
roster
in truth for a large portion of the
early series batman and superman
remained absent
the reason for this was because their
solo stories were some of dc's highest
selling at the time
as a result fans largely believed that
each comic was on a day-by-day basis and
that if superman or batman were to
suddenly appear in a justice league
comic
it would end up causing confusion in
terms of continuity furthermore the
basis behind the justice league was to
provide dual exposure for the rest of
the lineup and that their solo stories
continued
but in order to keep them popular they
were put together on a team which kept
them fresh in the minds of fans
while sales would dip occasionally
whenever this happened dc would
introduce batman and superman into a
story
in order to reinvigorate interest and
then remove them once sales had
increased again
in addition to this with a flash of two
worlds establishing the multiverse in
in august in september of 1963 with
issues 21 and 22
under gardner fox dc launched a two-part
story titled crisis on earth 1 and
crisis on earth 2
which saw the golden age justice society
reintroduced and teaming up
with the silver age justice league to
fight villains from both universes
while this would see the first time that
these two teams met one another
because it was so well received by fans
the team-ups between the two groups was
continued and in august of 1964 with
issue number 27
dc had both groups face off against the
evil version of the justice league
called the crime syndicate of america
and a story titled the i who defeated
the justice league
however by issue number 65 in 1968 while
he had removed wonder woman and
introduced black canary green arrow and
the atom in her stead
gardner fox left the title and was
replaced by dennis o'neill
with superman's popularity increasing
due to more weissinger's expansion of
the character which also included more
space-faring adventures
o'neill sought to include this element
into the justice league title
launching a story called snapper car
super trader o'neill had snapper tricked
by the joker into revealing the location
of the justice league's hidden base of
operations in happy harbor
using this information joker then
adopted the fake identity of john doe
and revealed this location
in addition to launching a campaign
aimed at accusing the justice league
of intending to overthrow the government
while the joker was captured and
defeated
o'neil removed the team from happy
harbor under the pretense that a new
location was needed
and in issue number 78 placed the
justice league in space
using an old satellite as their new base
of operations
while dennis o'neil's first run was
short-lived and that he had departed the
title after issue number 99
during his time right in the justice
league he began the process of deviating
away from the standard figure of heroes
battling villains
and began to introduce more politically
charged themes
furthermore with justice league issue
number 71 following the introduction of
new mars and a dwindling appearance in
the series due to a lack of popularity
among readers and poor sales from his
own stories
dennis o'neill wrote a story titled
death orbit which centered on the
reintroduction of martian manhunter's
race
and their desire to include him among
their ranks as a result the justice
league title saw the removal of martian
manhunter in addition to dc cancelling
his own solo series
however with issue number 99 dennis
o'neil had left the series in order to
help neil adams
revitalize green era within the pages of
adventure comics and in turn
the justice league title was handed over
to lynn wine who wrote issues 100-114
while lynn wine kept the element of the
satellite headquarters of the justice
league
over the course of his time in the
series he continued the trend of adding
various members of the dc hero community
to the league's roster
including the elongated man in issue
number 105 and red tornado in issue
number 106
however by issue number 115 wine had
left the series and was replaced by a
series of writers for issues 115 through
including kerry bates elliot s morgan
and jerry conway
while jerry conway had been writing for
both marvel and dc at the time
with stories from action comics and
adventure comics among others
as well as the creation of characters
like power girl following his story of
the night gwen stacey died in 1972 for
marvel comics and is shoveling around
the marvel landscape
he eventually left marvel and became the
lead writer for the justice league of
america
with issue number 151 in 1978
considered to be one of the
longest-running writers of the series
which ended with issue number 255
during his time on the title jerry
conway maintained much of the
established history
of the team including the introduction
of new members crossovers with the
earth-2 justice society of america
which included the 1979 crossover story
that also saw the death of terry sloane
the original mr terrific from the golden
age of comics
however because the marvel titles like
the x-men were incorporating more
teenage elements into their stories as
well as real world events
in justice league annual number two in
1994 titled the end of the justice
league
the team was completely revamped with
the original members of batman the flash
green lantern superman and wonder woman
replaced by a new team with both
familiar and younger faces
including aquaman zatanna elongated man
the vixen and a trio of teenage boys
gypsy steel and vibe as well as the
returning martian manhunter
while the title lasted three years fans
began to drop off due to a lack of
interest and with issue number 261 in
dc canceled the new line as part of
their year-long plan to reboot their
entire continuity
with crisis on infinite earths
so following the crisis on infinite
earth event in 1987 in dc's relaunch of
the various titles
because the justice league of america
was initially considered to be so
popular among readers
dc kept this series going under the
control of keith griffin and jmd
matthias
however rather than having a team
centered on american-centric members
instead
griffin expanded the team to become an
international group that would serve to
protect the world as a whole
rather than america itself while the
justice league was functioning as a
worldwide group
what this change did was allow dc to
incorporate a more multicultural lineup
among its members
to this end the new title maintained the
name justice league but because the
fallout from crisis on infinite earth
saw superman wonder woman and the flash
being revamped or relaunched by john
byrne george perez and mike baron
respectively
the original roster consisted of batman
black canary blue beetle captain marvel
dr fate dr light guy gardner martian
manhunter
mr miracle and abron with this new team
taking the justice league name for the
first six issues with issue number seven
the title was officially named justice
league international
furthermore because the stories within
contained both comedy and action
the title was successful among readers
and in april of 1989
dc launched a companion series called
justice league europe
moving keith griffin and dematteius away
from the international team to this new
title
the original team of jle consisted of
captain adam as the field commander
who led the elongated man power girl
wally west rocket red
animal man and metamorpho following this
the justice league international title
was renamed to justice league america
justice league europe was renamed to
justice league international and dc
launched two more companion series in
the form of extreme justice and justice
league task force
while each of these proved to be
successful in their own initial
introduction
after the departure of demeteus and
griffin in 1991 these various titles
were consistently rotated among various
artists and writers
as a result there was very little
consistency among the titles and while
efforts were made to incorporate top
tier heroes like superman batman aquaman
and the flash the constant changes in
retcons left fans with a bad taste and
so by 1996
dc cancelled all of the justice league
titles launching a three-part
mini-series titled a mid-summer's
nightmare
writer mark wade and artist fabian
neciza disbanded the justice league
international
europe task force and extreme justice
titles
using this as a platform under dc editor
mike carlin
writer grant morrison began the new
justice league line titled jla
with a four-issue mini-series called new
world order
centering on a group of alien invaders
referred to as the hyperclan which
sought to use mind control as a way to
turn earth citizens against their
superheroes
the original justice league of superman
wonder woman aquaman the flash
batman and green lantern came together
for the purpose of defeating the hyper
clan
with a story ending in their success in
january of 1997 the justice league was
renamed to jla
in addition to this rather than
launching a series of branch off teams
dc instead chose to focus its efforts on
multiple one-shots and mini-series
depicting the core justice league team
working alongside other superheroes
furthermore with morrison departing
after issue number 41 the series saw
stories under the writing of joe kelly
mark wade kurt busayek
and bob harris however since this new
leak included most of dc's most powerful
heroes
the focus of the stories changed in that
the league now only dealt with
earth-shattering highest priority
threats
which could challenge their tremendous
combined power in addition
because almost all of the members had
their own comics the stories were almost
always self-contained
with all chapters occurring within jla
itself and very rarely affecting events
outside of that series as a result while
the continuity was easy to follow
during the events of 2005's infinite
crisis which served as one of several
crises designed to correct the
continuity issues that remained
following crisis on infinite earth dc
elected to cancel the jla title as part
of their series of retcons in order to
reboot the series yet again
with a more refreshing look at the
characters to this end
in 2006 following the conclusion of
infinite crisis
underwriter brad meltzer dc introduced
justice league of america volume 2
issue number zero serving as a jumping
off platform issue number zero saw
superman batman and wonder woman meeting
for the purpose of reforming the league
and by the time the story completed had
a roster composed of the aforementioned
heroes
in addition to the green lantern hal
jordan black canary red arrow red
tornado
vixen black lightning and hot girl while
the popularity of this team would prove
to be equally successful in comparison
to its previous iterations
following the flashpoint event in 2011
and the launch of the new 52
the justice league of america title was
canceled once again and replaced by the
justice league series under the writing
of jeff
johns with that being said we're going
to bring this video to an end i hope you
guys enjoyed it and i will catch you
guys later
peace